daddy is with us in California hi Patti
how can we help
I gave him Kristen Simoes for taking my
call
so I am 25 years old and I just got
accepted into an accelerated nursing
program that I'm gonna start in
September and I currently have no debt
from my previous bachelor's or any other
kind of debt and I'm gonna have to take
out a student loan in order to finance
this education and I just want to figure
out the the wisest way for me to to pay
for schools and I don't end up in a big
hole at the end of it you're not gonna
like us okay we teach people to not
borrow money yeah you knew that right I
knew that I've been listening to your
show for quite a while and mine in the
history of your listening in the history
of your listening have you ever heard us
say ever to anyone to borrow money no
I'm not
probably not changing that today so how
can we figure out a way to help you
because we can't help you with your
question I can't help you borrow money
because I know it because I don't think
that's wise for you okay I don't I mean
I love accelerate nursing program I love
what you're talking about doing you love
the field you're in but if you were my
daughter I would tell you not to borrow
money to do this I'm gonna have to find
another way to do this instead of just
accepting accepting the cultural norm of
going into student loan debt mm-hmm
because patty you said you had avoided
debt even for undergrad so how did you
pay for the undergrad yeah there was a
combination of a college fund that my
grandparents and my parents had set up
for me and then some substantial
scholarships that I was offered okay so
what is this cost the cost of yeah so
the total cost including living expenses
is going to be around 47,000
and 700 that's how you have to change
cities yes yeah and they're working and
living expenses are you working in
nursing now no I'm not I am currently
working in a service industry okay and
so did you get a degree in nursing
already and are this is the become a
nurse this is to become a nurse my first
degree was in ecology so I worked in
River assessment for a couple of years
and then decided that I wanted to switch
over to nursing okay but you're in a
service industry now yes yeah what do
you make now I make $15 an hour okay so
and you're living on that I'm currently
living with my parents I've been home
for the last five months okay and what
city do you live in I live in a small
town man's Lake California how far away
is the nursing program that you the
nursing program is in Iowa whoa how'd
you get the fellowship on the other
bridge yeah great so my plan is
obviously to apply for scholarships and
I've already submitted my FAFSA so I
should be getting some kind of financial
aid from the federal government and then
the application period for scholarships
opens in October so I will of course be
submitting such you're stronger than me
all I do yeah they had an application
period open in March but I wasn't aware
that I would I was accepted into the
program okay there's lots of places you
can apply for a scholarship they're not
the only place okay yeah I also would
start talking to hospital companies like
the HCA's of the world there's a nursing
shortage
and talk to them and see if they have
programs where they will assist you in
your nursing school costs in return you
promise to work for them maybe when you
come out for a number of years or
whatever there are programs like that
out there floating around but what I
just jump and go fifty grand in debt
without having done anything else just
because you got accepted in Iowa and you
live in California no I might tap the
brakes on it probably gonna have to
because you simply don't have the money
and you're getting ready to go deeply in
debt and if you don't finish or you
don't pass your boards you're right back
to trying to pay off 50 grand with a
$15.00 an hour job again okay so you so
the risk of taking out the loan you
think are greater than the benefit of
yes being able to make significant way
more money than I am yes
after having talked to the 32 year old
version of you for 30 years who's up a
freakin Creek mm-hmm because they made
these choices and then they end up
getting married and one lady I remember
I'll never forget I was just heartbroken
she got married and had her first child
who had all kinds of medical needs and
she wanted to quit and go home and stay
with this a child that needed its mother
at home and she couldn't do it because
she had $100,000 in student loans
because these are the things you when
life unfolds you don't see this stuff no
you really don't Dave and I'm gonna tell
you I know you know Patti you're sitting
there you're thinking this is a great
opportunity and this is the time for you
and it's the doors are opening up and
it's not it's actually trap doors that
are opening up that have swallowed
unfortunately 44 million Americans
around to the tune of 1.7 trillion in
student loan debt and I would forego
this for a year until I could save up or
as dave said look for scholarships or
companies for internships I'm gonna
figure out every way possible but not
signing these student loan documents and
Patti I'm telling you something I'm
talking to the four-year older version
of you I hope you take this option off
the table I hope you don't just hear us
and it rattles around in your head for a
little bit and you still pick up that
pin because it is that it is a costly
pin to sign those two loans I hope you
don't
I really do and you can follow that
dream but you have to follow it in a
different direction
and you do your dream their own way and
ends up being a nightmare who and it's
just um that's what happens you know and
I've just talked to tens of thousands of
Patti's mm that wish they hadn't done
this mm-hmm and it only works if it all
works perfect huh and it never works
perfect in life and no we're done kind
of like when you got the ecology degree
yeah it didn't work out now what if you
know what happens if dot dot dot and you
know that's that's what copepod shutting
everything down underlined for people
everywhere is that their plan that they
had sucked yeah and it and the when you
stress test a bad plan it comes up
stupid and that's what happens so I just
hope it doesn't stress test you but but
Patti there's a reason you've never
heard us telling him by to borrow money
it's not just because we're killjoys or
dream killers it's because it's quite
the opposite we want good things for you
we love you we want you to win okay we
did not win that last one what do you
mean she's gonna get a student loan you
think so Dave I don't think we want it
did you think we know cuz I mean she
started the conversation she'd already
done the deal was already done in her
head yeah and I don't think we turned
that car around no you're probably right
and you know I hate that I hate I hate
to think that because we only have a
brief period of time right to try to
convey it to someone but as you said
you've been talking to 30 year old
Patti's for 30 years now what what do we
do how do we help people to realize
because you said it the perfect plan
never happens well it just it doesn't
once somebody gets her dream and the you
know the horse leaves have Barnum and
she's going on the interstate in 75
miles an hour we had to make her stop
get off the exit and turn and go the
other way that's right and I don't even
know if we slowed we slowed her down but
I don't think she got off the exit I
don't think she turned around hmm I
don't know maybe maybe maybe we gave her
something to think about
maybe I don't be
the thing is this the entire culture has
lost its mind and when you adopt the
values of a culture that allows and
encourages American young people to go
very soon to be two trillion dollars in
debt yeah
to get a degree and some degrees are
valid in the summer ridiculous that is a
valid degree it's a valid degree but
what she put on the table was a hundred
percent financing mm-hmm for a program
all the way across the United States
from her family which is not that that's
survivable you can do that right but
there was no no tip of the hat to the
way she did the other thing even there
was no she said it very quickly
her grandparents had a college fund and
she had some scholarships and a
fellowship yeah and which means that
she's bright she avoided it at some
point then and you know what they people
do get stupid I remember going to grad
school and it there is a thing in your
mind that says this will guarantee me
more money this master's will guarantee
and it's almost posed in your brain that
you're almost if you get accepted then
you're stupid if you don't do it yeah
and that's why it's failing right now so
when we should when we stopped and
suggestion that it felt stupid right
that's what I heard yeah no you're also
held in the spirit cuz here's what she's
thinking if I can play devil's advocate
she's thinking I'm gonna get out I'm
gonna make a tea if I owe for tea seven
I'm gonna live on 30-something and pay
it yah-ha no you won't he doesn't work
out you won't I'm gonna tell you right
now you won't because you've opened the
door and you're gonna keep adding to it
and it's stacking and then it's the
couple you talked about the Delaney that
had the sick child that she wanted to
stay at home with I'll take it a step
further it's a young couple that meets
that's wanting to get married and then
have a baby and then somebody wants to
be at home and you qualified for this
debt with this double income and now
you're trying to survive on one you just
dug the hole you dug the hole so paddy
put the shovel down and think long-term
for you I guess what you hear is really
one old guy and one younger dude me I'm
the younger one and this duo trying to
trying to give you some life guidance
and if you won't listen to the old one
lost your credibility no I mean when you
lie on the radio what's your right day
people get going down the road that's so
fast I guess I want him to hear the pain
we've heard sitting across from people
you know I mean we're just you know our
whole job is not only put up a speed
bump it's put up a wall yeah it just
says you can't go here you can't go here
get Anthony should have given her that
book
Anthony O'Neill's debt-free degree yes
there's another thing I goofed on that
call but um you know in a sense what
we're doing when we're trying to teach
you folks the shortest distance between
where you are and your best possible
life as far as wealth building goes
highs dollars of wealth the shortest
distance is not through debt it's proven
time and time and time again it always
feels like here's the other thing 100
percent of time you talk to wealthy
people that started with nothing like
all the millionaire's that we
interviewed a hundred percent of time
they tell you to make a decision that
hurts now financially that causes you to
prosper later don't make a decision
that's easy now that hurts you later
and that's always debt it is it's easy
now to sign up for these payments and I
Drive off a lot in a shiny new truck
that's easy but it hurts you later
it sure does hard to do what you know
young man we talked about in the last
hour talk to in the last hour you came
home from work every day for three years
and built his own house with his hands
that's hard now but now he's sitting
there with a paid for home and you know
so if it's easy now and hard later it's
the wrong financial decision
and that's what that's what it always is
- by the way you can anything you want
to put through that lens that filter
will help you make financial decisions
if it's easy now if it's easy money if
it's quick money if it's get-rich-quick
the Bible says he who hastens to be rich
is in a hurry to be rich will not go
unpunished
it doesn't say sometimes you get by
it says will not go unpunished
get-rich-quick 100% of time will kick
you in the teeth
easy payments will always set you up in
a mess so what feels like it's smart
right now but it's easy right now it's
the path of least resistance is what
people do with student loans mm-hmm
instead of figuring I'm gonna sweat I'm
gonna work I'm gonna get apply to more
different colleges find a cheaper deal
find one within range of my home so I
can live at home and get rid of the
living expenses yeah I'm gonna get
scholarships I'm gonna you know I'm
gonna work my tail oh yes and you know
I'm gonna wait a year that's none of
this is easy yeah but when you're 32
versus 25 you look back you'll go man
that was smart that's right it is no
you're absolutely right I tell it when I
was coaching people I want you to make
2-year decisions I want you to make a
decision that you'll look back on in two
years and you're glad you made it right
and that's the stuff that puts you on
the path so just for the other young
people out there that are listening just
hear this hear this yield hear this kind
of you know I like that Dave throwing up
a wall because I'm tired of people
climbing it and then falling down into
this pit and then helping trying to dig
them out they're trying to dig
themselves out for 15 years avoid that
pit yeah go in another direction
go find some nurses that have $50,000
$100,000 in debt and ask them if they
think they'd do it again uh-huh you know
they won't tell you to do it you know
they will not no they will not I say I
would have done it I would
I think being a nurse is a great idea
but I would have done it a different way
that's right though you're right or
anything fill-in-the-blank nurse
whatever recipe employed in that tourney
doctor I mean just walk down through the
list because we've counts with all of
them well yeah so I there's not a proven
methodology for convincing someone who's
already decided anything and so but but
guys we just I mean it's real simple
with us
we're not primitive or actually have
been doing this for decades this is a
very sophisticated organization and a
sophisticated train of thought and it a
these are proven points of data mm-hmm
they're proven that the shortest
distance between where you are right now
and where you want to go a wealth wise
is of getting out of debt and avoiding
debt and building an emergency fund and
living on a budget and so forth so with
these crazy times right now if you have
said never again you don't be at the
mercy of anything including even global
crisis never again with a new cycle put
you in a panic if you've got a plan and
you have savings and you don't have any
debt you you're gonna be a different
place because this has happened to you
and scared you the new Ramsey Plus
program there's a free trial going on
right now and you need to check it out
it includes all the Financial Peace
University it includes sinking on every
dollar it includes the new baby steps
out check it all out at Dave Ramsey
dot-com Ramsey Plus free trial